Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and today we're going to talk about a product
that we have in our line called Laptid Balancer and Laptid Balancer.
It's for weight loss for people who want to lose those extra pounds whether they're very
obese or want to lose that 10 extra pounds.
This is a product that you want to put in here, right?
Obviously, excess weight we've spoken about this before is common, seriously, serious leads
to other diseases and it's very costly.
I'm not going to read the slide to you, go ahead and look at that.
You know what's an issue?
It leads to other diseases.
It may be the bottom line of most of our diseases that are changeable and we need to address
it.
But it's hard to address, gosh, one of those weight, I know I need to lose weight and I should
stop eating so much and exercise more.
Easier said than done, right?
That's all the honest.
One of our problems is Laptid.
What's Laptid?
Never even heard of Laptid.
Well, Laptid is a hormone that's made by your fat cells that basically tells you you're
full.
It's your satiation hormone.
It's what tells you to stop eating.
The problem is the more that we eat, either through emotional means or because our food
supply is laden with sugar and glutamates that make us think that we're more hungry and
make us eat more.
The Laptid receptors, the receptors that receive the hormone onto the cell membrane can become
damaged.
Those Laptid receptors become stripped and then Laptid can't communicate to your cells and
your neural tissue to tell you that you're full.
We get what's called Laptid resistance, kind of like insulin resistance.
It's almost exactly like insulin resistance and a diabetic patient.
We end up with Laptid resistance and then we don't get those satiation signals and we're
not full, so we keep eating and when we keep eating, we're going to gain weight.
One of the problems that we have with weight loss is not that people are necessarily
continuing to be hungry, but they don't get that stuff.
I got to steep.
He stopped eating, feeling.
This product, Laptid balancer, is really for the patient who, yeah, I don't know why I'm
just hungry all the time, I'm just to keep eating and I'm hungry.
We have to eat lunch.
Well, honey, we just eat breakfast two hours ago.
I don't want to be hungry.
That's who this product really shines for.
Laptid balancer has subduetrians in there, one of the biggest things is the oral visc that
has been proven to decrease our elected and increase the sensitivity of our elected receptors.
It's been numerous studies and if you need to look them up there on our store, actually,
so this is linked to a study here, out here, number nine.
So there's numerous studies that we show on the product, light on the store, but this
is a really cool 25-week-old mice, this is the mice model study, we're fed this product
here in order to see if it would help with weight loss.
Well, animals treated with Laptid balancer tended to lose more body weight or quickly than
those in the control group.
The ones who use this product, Laptid balancer, showed a higher and faster loss of body
fat, a body weight by switching their diet and using this product.
And when the animals were sacrificing the study, they noticed a 30% lower and circulating
Laptid levels were 40% lower in the treated animals.
We're also displayed reduced Laptid gene expression, which is so important with insulin
and Laptid sensitivity.
So if we could increase the sensitivity of our Laptid receptors, we need that they're going
to respond to the Laptid that is in the tissue better to give you that satiation feeling,
you're going to feel more full.
Again, this product is for people who tend to be hungry a lot and tend to eat too much
because they're hungry.
So this will help with Laptid sensitivity, help with Laptid resistance issues, thereby help
increase your satiation feeling, your feeling of fullness and your decrease your desire to
continue eating, you'll push away from the plate more readily, you'll put less food on
your plate, you'll be less looking for something to eat on a regular basis.
A great product to try, Laptid balancer, tie it in with the appetite balancer, tie it
in with our lead probiotic, it's a great package to help lose weight.
All right, thanks much.